-I'm very excited.
There's a lot of fun things
going on right now.
Thanksgiving
is only two days away.
-Ooh!
-Right? Yes.
I have a --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I have a new holiday song out
with Dolly Parton called
"Almost Too Early
for Christmas."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
So, I released this song
in October.
-Right.
-I thought that would be --
-Almost too early.
-It's almost too early.
-Right.
-It's before Mariah.
-Yeah.
You play this song, it's just
a little too early to play.
It's not --
We're not ready for the song.
Anyways, I talked about it
on the show
and I said, "You know what would
be a dream for me?
Is if we could be
the on-hold music
for the Butterball hotline.
-That'd be good. That's worthy.
-That's -- I mean, that's
where -- I mean, you're --
-That's "Top of the Pops," yeah.
-You're kind of stuck
there on the phone
waiting to get turkey tips
from Butterball.
-You've already messed up bad.
-Well, I mean, you got to know
how -- what to do.
You have stuffing questions.
There's side questions.
You have -- I mean,
it's probably things
outside of turkey, is it?
The Butterball hotline?
Or is it just turkey only?
-I bet if you asked them
about mashed potatoes,
they'd tell you.
-Yeah, they have to, right?
So, anyways, I heard that
Butterball said yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And that they --
So I thought, let's try it out
and see if we are the
on-hold music for Butterball.
-What is that?
-This is a phone.
-That's a phone?
-What do you mean what is this?
-I was born in '92, man.
-It's a telephone.
-I don't know what that is.
-Telephone, man.
-So, it's 1-800-Butterball,
right?
1-800-Butterball.
Do I have to press something?
-You have to do 9 to get out.
[ Dialing ]
I feel like Butterball is
longer than the actual number.
-Welcome to Butterball.
To be connected to our
Butterball Turkey Talk-Line,
for information on
turkey preparation
and cooking assistance,
press or say 3.
If you have a --
[ Beep ]
Your call may be
monitored or recorded
to ensure quality
customer service.
-I hope it is.
-Thank you for calling
the Butterball Turkey Talk-Line.
-You're welcome.
-All turkey experts
are assisting other callers.
Your estimated wait time
is about one minute.
For self-service options
to frequently asked questions...
-Get to the goods.
-...or visit butterball.com
for information on turkey
preparation, recipes, and more.
If you would like to leave
a call-back number
and keep your place in line,
press 2,
or remain on the line
for the next available expert.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes! Butterball!
Yes!
That is a Christmas miracle!
It's a Thanksgiving miracle!
Thank you, Butterball!